hello on behalf of my co-presenter
dr andrew roche we'd like to thank the
organizers
for this opportunity to talk about
biomarker essays
and more specifically the application of
a biomarker method
in a bioanalytical setting versus the
migration of that method
into a clear lab for clinical
development
but first a brief introduction about
ourselves
i have the privilege of overseeing the
bioanalytical group here at icon
whereas andy oversees the scientific
aspects
of our clia lab and more specifically
the introduction
and then oversight of those methods in
our clear labs
and so in today's talk we'll have the
following discussion items
first we'll provide some perspectives
about the use of biomarkers
then we'll talk about the different
levels of assay qualification required
between a biomarker method that might be
used in a bioanalytical
setting versus one that is being used in
clinical research
and we'll do that by the use of context
of use of those biomarker methods
certain methods may require full
bioanalytical validation
versus perhaps a companion diagnostic
that needs to follow a different
standard and then at the end of our talk
we'll provide some case studies
where we highlight some nuances of the
application of a biomarker method
depending on its context of use
and so let's now provide some
perspectives on the use of biomarkers
and so let's discuss fda's view on
biomarkers
now back in 2014 dr janet woodcock
gave a seminar to industry and in that
seminar she made mention of biomarkers
being extremely critical to drug
development
and there were three types of biomarkers
being discussed
and so the first class are disease
related
and so the presence of particular
biomarker may indicate your
susceptibility
to future disease a good example
is cholesterol and so measuring high
levels of cholesterol
may indicate potential cardiovascular
disease
further on in life and so in the early
2000s
industry academia and regulators got
together
and formed a non-profit organization
called the critical path institute
now the mission of this institute was to
identify
biomarkers that are early indicators
of disease and then correlate the
progression of disease
with the appearance of these biomarkers
and then there are the diagnostic
biomarkers
whose presence can confirm a diagnosis
of a particular disease
so for example if you have very high
levels of bilirubin
that could confirm a diagnosis of a
genetic disorder
and that will be something we'll discuss
in a case study at the end of our
presentation
and then we have the prognostic
biomarkers
those are used to determine the
feasibility of a particular
therapeutic intervention and its ability
to mitigate
a disease so for example if you have the
her2 receptor
and you've been diagnosed with breast
cancer
then perhaps the therapeutic
intervention with herceptin
would indicate a high degree of
success
and then we have the prognostic
biomarkers so-called precision medicine
and so a good example here is if you are
diagnosed with breast cancer
and you have the hurt and you are
then we have the prognostic biomarkers
which can be used for precision medicine
so for example if you've been
unfortunately diagnosed
with breast cancer and the cancer itself
has the her2 receptor
then that provides the opportunity to
intervene with herceptin
given that its target is the her2
receptor
so there's a high probability that that
therapeutic intervention
will be successful now it should come as
no surprise that up to 45
of drug approvals are using surrogate
endpoints
what we mean by this is that you can
measure a biomarker
as to show the disease mitigation or
disease progression
rather than actually waiting for a
clinical outcome
so for example you've got a high levels
of cholesterol cholesterol being the
biomarker
and then you intervene with a statin now
you could wait 20 years to see if the
patient had a cardiovascular event
or you can monitor the lowering of
cholesterol
thereby correlating the clinical outcome
with that surrogate endpoint
and so the logical extension of this are
companion diagnostics
with a drug company co-develops the in
vitro test
for a biomarker and then markets that
with the therapeutic drug itself
and so the combination of both are used
in a
precision medicine approach so the
example before where herceptin
use would require a companion diagnostic
to measure the presence of her2
receptors to thereby provide some
assurance
that the therapeutic intervention might
be successful
so what types of common sponsor requests
we see here at icon
being a clinical research organization
supporting clinical development
and so within that proposal we will see
requests for
and so within that proposal there are
requests
to measure exploratory endpoints in the
clinical protocol
and these may be standard panels for
example cytokines
and so icon is a contract research
organization
that supports clinical research and so
sponsors come to us with requests
to support various aspects of their
clinical protocol
and so contained within a proposal are
requests for certain biomarker
measurements
and they fall into one of three
categories there are those that support
exploratory endpoints
and so these might be a standard panel
to understand the therapeutic effect
of a drug on a patient
now for example we might be measuring
cytokines and so with icon being a
contract research organization
supporting clinical research we see
sponsor requests
for certain biomarkers and so contained
within a clinical protocol
are various endpoints those might be
exploratory
primary or secondary
exploratory endpoints often measure
biomarkers
as a standard panel looking for a safety
signal
or in some instances looking actually
for an early efficacy signal
now we might be measuring cytokine
panels
or we might be looking at oxidative
stress biomarkers for
indication of potential harm
similarly we might be looking for
pro-inflammatory biomarkers
and that decrease with a ther you know
with a particular
therapeutic intervention
and then we have primary or secondary
endpoints
for the most part primary endpoints are
typically those related to safety
although in a phase 3 trial it's a
combination of safety and
efficacy
now the primary endpoint could be
a
a common secondary endpoint is looking
for target engagement
and so the disappearance of particular
soluble protein
the soluble protein being the biomarker
would be indicative
of a monoclonal antibody therapeutic
binding that soluble protein and
removing it
from circulation then we have prognostic
or even diagnostic biomarkers
that are used as primary or secondary
endpoints
you are so full as [ __ ]
and then we have primary or secondary
endpoints
for the most part primary endpoints are
typically related to safety
or patient safety
and then we have primary or secondary
end points and for the most part
primary endpoints are those related
directly to patient safety
but sometimes they can be looking for
efficacy readouts
more often than not the secondary
endpoints are things like the
pharmacokinetics
in other words the clearance of the
particular drug or we could be looking
at a diagnostic biomarker
for the appearance or disappearance of
particular indicator of disease
another example is target engagement so
we have a soluble protein
that is disease related
and we can be looking at a monoclonal
antibody whose job it is is to bind that
soluble protein and take it out of
circulation
and then we have the class of biomarkers
that are used to stratify a patient
population
for enrollment into a clinical trial
these are so-called inclusion or
exclusion biomarkers so the presence of
a particular biomarker at a certain
level
may be sufficient to exclude that
subject
from the clinical trial or conversely
being from a precision medicine
standpoint
the appearance of that biomarker may be
exactly what we're looking for for entry
into the clinical trial
let's now move on to regulatory
considerations
and for this part of the talk i'm going
to be focused on bioanalytical
now the fda back in 2018 issued a
bioanalytical
method validation guidance this was an
update from a previous one that was
issued in 2001
and so within the context of that
guidance
are topics that relate to biomarkers
the concept of fit for purpose is
introduced
and it talks to the level of validation
that may be required for particular
analytes
and so if a biomarker is being measured
and it is a primary endpoint
and the study itself is pivotal to
submission
and requires a regulatory decision fda
are expecting
that that biomarker be contained within
the guidance
is the concept of fit for purpose now
fit for purpose as it applies to
biomarkers
contained within the fda guidance is the
concept of fit for purpose
and this concept relates to the level of
rigor
that a bioanalytical method might be
validated
or sometimes called qualified
contained within the guidance is this
concept of fit for purpose
and fit for purpose for biomarker
measurements
relates to how that data is being used
so for example if it is a pivotal study
being submitted and are looking for
regulatory decision
then i then any method that is being
used for decision making
needs to be fully validated so if you're
measuring a biomarker
and it is the clint it is the primary
endpoint
for that clinical trial then the method
for that biomarker
needs to be fully validated whereas on
the other hand
if you have exploratory endpoints that
it may be used for
internal decision making then the
requirement for
rigorous validation is not there
and then on the other hand we have
biomarkers
that are being used for exploratory
endpoints
in other words more likely to be used
for internal decision making
than being submitted for a regular
decision and so in those cases a
biomarker method does not require
full validation nonetheless a sponsor
may require of a bioanalytical lab a
higher degree
of qualification than might be necessary
so in those circumstances where the
biomarker measurement
is being used to support support an
exploratory endpoint
the requirement to follow all of the
assessments spelled out in the guidance
may not be necessary now it's not to say
that a sponsor may request of a
contract research organization a high
degree of confidence
even for internal decision making and so
it all does come down to fit for purpose
and what is intended use of that data
represents for that for that sponsor
on this slide we provide a process flow
that might be used to guide the level of
assay rigor
required for a particular biomarker
method
one of the first things that needs to be
determined is how is the clinical trial
assay the cta being used
is the biomarker method being used to
support a pkpd correlation
is it being used for enrolling or
stratifying a patient population
or in fact is the biomarker measurement
correlating
drug safety and so in the first box
we ask the question is the clinical
trial assay being used for a secondary
or an exploratory endpoint
well the answer is yes then you would
revert to using a bioanalytical approach
really being fit for purpose you may or
may not
fulfill all of the assessments spelled
out in the fda guidance
but you would do what would be required
to answer the specific question
and if the answer is no you must ask the
question is the
method being used to support patient
response to the therapy
but not necessarily for a direct
treatment decision
and so again here's an example where
you're talking about biomarkers that
might be primary
or secondary endpoints to the clinical
protocol
may yet be submitted for fda decision or
a label claim
and in which case you would then be
required to follow the fda's guidance
for bioanalytical method validation
conversely
if the clinical trial assay is being
used to support a primary endpoint
being used for patient selection
if it's being used for the decision to
treat or as a safety endpoint
and might be considered as an eventual
companion diagnostic
then the thought is that you need to
undergo a clear validation
and that is something that my
co-presenter andy will talk to
the next question being asked then is is
the cta being used to validate
the method for a potential ivd
submission
or it's going to be used as a companion
diagnostic
and if the answer is yes then there is a
whole series of requirements
under the clsi requirement
now the next question being asked is is
the
and so the next question in the process
flow is whether or not
the clinical trial assay is going to be
progressed
to an ivd to an in vitro diagnostic
or as a companion diagnostic
and in those circumstances you would
follow the requirements
spelled out in clsi and again that is
something that my co-presenter will
touch on
and so now over the next few slides
we'll go into a little bit more depth
with the application of biomarker
methods in a bioanalytical context
and so on this slide we're going to talk
about context of use
biomarker methods those that are used
for research use only
or in other words internal decision
making
now that could be a standard panel of
safety biomarkers
which are thought to be important for a
particular therapeutic area
and that might include things like a
pro-inflammatory cytokine
so if you look looking at arthritis or
copd
you might be interested in the presence
or absence of certain cytokines
similarly if similarly
if your drug's mechanism of action may
induce
oxidative stress measurement of
particular biomarkers
might be quite important
and then in phase one studies we might
want to have an early readout
of clinical efficacy and so we could be
looking at
soluble targets and use those
now in phase one where our primary focus
is in safety and tolerability of a
therapeutic
we may want to get an early readout of
clinical efficacy
and so in those cases you might measure
a particular biomarker
and then correlate that to the drug
levels in other words pkpd
and so in phase one where the primary
concern is patient safety
you may still want to have an early
readout of clinical efficacy
and so in those cases you might measure
a biomarker
and then correlate that to drug levels
now the phase one study is often not
powered sufficiently
to make any clear decision on efficacy
but it could be sufficient to show
target engagement
and at least a hint of therapeutic
activity
that biomarker may in fact become a
secondary or even a primary endpoint in
subsequent clinical trials
now that data is not likely to be used
for
regulatory decision and yet it could
still be included
in a submission package
and so continuing on with that
discussion exploratory endpoints are
often used to answer scientific
questions
and so what sort of assay rigor might we
use for that bioanalytical method
for an exploratory endpoint again just
reiterating an explanatory endpoint is
for
internal decision making and not for
regulatory
decision some biomarkers might be
measured with a commercial kit
a good example is a cytokine panel in a
multiplexed format
now ordinarily you'd want to assess
precision
you'd look for parallelism if you're
using an elisa type kit
and in those cases you'd use incurred
samples that you would dilute to see if
upon dilution you are able to return a
similar result
one thing you will want to look at is
selectivity of the biomarker method
in the presence of drug commercial kit
vendors
have no knowledge of your therapeutic
drug and have developed their kits
to measure the biomarker in the absence
of pretty much everything
oftentimes the calibrators and quality
controls
are prepared in buffer and so if your
drug is interacting with the
biomarker it's likely that the
commercial kit
may fail
now because biomarkers are not
immediately analyzed
you'd want to understand the stability
of your analyte
in the matrix that was being collected
simply speaking we were talking about
benchtop stability
and maybe a freeze and thought cycle
prior to analysis
now as previously mentioned some
commercial kits
use buffers for the calibrators and qc
levels
and so it is important to understand the
acceptability of the results from those
commercial kits
in actual patient samples
and so what you might do is obtain
commercial matrix
and look for endogenous levels of the of
that analyte
or as best as you can over the dynamic
range
of your assay now if you're
fortunate and you have recombinant
protein you may spike on top of
endogenous levels
to obtain concentrations that span the
dynamic range of your assay
and then you might assess that method
over say three
core runs activity of your assay
is often best accomplished using the
parallelism assessment
now what that looks like is that you may
spike your analyte into buffer and get
an instrument response
and then look at buffer diluted matrix
over different dilution factors
and then comparing the signal to that
buffer spike
now the op4 in that assessment is at a
certain dilution
the instrument response reads back the
same concentration that's often called
the minimum required dilution
so if you're fortunate and can get away
with a a twofold dilution
then the acid sensitivity would be quite
reasonable but there are some
soluble proteins that may require 100 or
even one of a thousand dilution
in which case the sensitivity of the
assay is directly
impacted by the level of dilution needed
now how do we go about establishing
acceptance criteria for our exploratory
method
now clearly we could follow the fda
guidance and for chromatographic assays
plus a minus 15
accuracy precision or for a protein
therapeutic plus or minus 20
and so if you're looking for fold
changes in biomarker concentrations
then using absolute accuracy precision
criteria from the guidance
may not necessarily be appropriate
so for example you might establish bias
criteria
based on plus or minus two or three
times what you saw
for assay precision during the
qualification process
and so we've discussed what you might do
for a biomarker method
being used for an exploratory endpoint
let's look at the other end of the
spectrum
and so we're looking at pharmacodynamic
endpoints
that will be submitted for regulatory
decision
and as i showed in the previous slide on
the fda bioanalytical guidance
any analyte that is going to be
submitted for regulatory decision
needs to be fully validated
now what does full validation mean for a
biomarker method
and so what does that mean for a
biomarker method validation
well first you'd want to assess
parallelism in other words
understanding the impact of the matrix
on the quantitation of your biomarker
you'd be looking at precision of the
measurement
now ideally you'd be using incurred
samples but sometimes those incurred
samples may be
fortified with recombinant protein
you'd be looking at selectivity and as i
mentioned before selectivity meaning
in the presence of drug particularly if
the drug
is targeting binding of the biomarker
assay sensitivity standard requirement
for bioanalytical methods
specificity of the method and then
understanding the stability of your
analyte
from the process from collection to
analysis
in other words you'll be looking at
short-term stability maybe bench top or
refrigerated storage
you'll be looking at the impact of
freezing thor cycles on the analyte
and of course long-term storage
the matrix that you prepare your
biomarker
qcs in needs to match study samples
so with commercial kits often being
provided with using buffer
that would not be appropriate for a full
validation
and so what that typically means is that
you're going to screen endogenous matrix
looking for matrix lots
that have either low levels that you can
then fortify
or you have disease stamp samples
that can then be covering the entire
dynamic range of your method
sometimes obtaining disease samples from
a commercial vendor is quite challenging
and so it is acceptable to use
recombinant
spikes now in those circumstances when
your biomarker is present in
matrix it is acceptable to use a
surrogate matrix for the calibration
levels
now what is important is that your
endogenous qc levels do read back
reliably when you are using a
calibration curve prepared
in surrogate matrix
now throughout the validation process
you will be assessing endogenous qcs
and once you're through the validation
process you'll take then the mean
concentrations from those endogenous qcs
and then use a pull for sample analysis
the idea of course is that what you've
determined during validation
is replicated in sample analysis
now before i hand it off to my
co-presenter andy
i thought i would show you how we've
operationalized the differences between
bioanalytical and clear
so within the icon laboratory services
umbrella
we've got distinct units that focus on
bioanalytical methods
as well as the central lab doing
traditional clear
safety testing
and where there is overlap we refer to
that as specialty services
so for example we might have a
traditional pharmacokinetic assay
where we're measuring the large or small
molecule
using elisa or lcms but in that same
group we might also do biomarkers
given that the platforms are identical
between doing a drug
versus the biomarker and so where we
have
overlap we call that group specialty
services
it might have a biomarker that might
have been exploratory
and done the bioanalytical lab is now
potentially becoming
a enrollment criteria
and that needs to be then done in the
clear lab
and so we would transition the assay
from the bioanalytical setting
and then into clear which is what andy
will talk about next
and so in upcoming slides andy will now
discuss what is required
for a biomarker method transitioning
from a bioanalytical setting
to now into clinical research where the
results from the biomarker measurements
are going to be used for you know
patient enrollment
inclusion exclusion criteria or
be reported to the clinical site but
dose decisions
to discuss the factors that are
important to consider
when reporting results to clinical sites
firstly
for u.s based labs it is essential and
there's a federal requirement that those
labs have
clear accreditation in addition
many labs for example including those
participating in clinical trials
will also opt to obtain and maintain
the college of american pathologists or
cap accreditation
this is an industry standard
accreditation which builds
on the requirements of clear cap
have a mission of fostering and
advocating excellence in the practice of
pathology and abortion medicine
worldwide
worldwide and accreditation by cap also
covers
off your clear requirements a further
point
to consider for labs based in new york
state or for a lab to wish
to report results to citizens of new
york state
it is also essential in those scenarios
that the lab
obtains a either a new york city permit
uh or a licenses that they can report
results
for subjects based in new york state
in addition the clsi the clinical and
laboratory standards institute also
provide a number of
guidelines that can provide more detail
and more guidance on how to perform our
specific studies
typically these guidelines are of
uh i suppose more specific benefit in
designing any exact experiments as
compared to capriclea who will tell you
for example that you must do a study
access to diy without actually saying
uh how to do that study so clsr are very
valuable in that respect
they provide various procedures that
cover
um methods from start you know the
lifespan of methods from start to end
and some of the particularly useful
methods that many labs would use would
include for example
ep 28 which defines
the establishment and or verification of
reference intervals in the clinical
laboratory setting
and also ep 15 user verification of
decision
and estimation advice so these documents
are very helpful to uh to use from a
clinically voluntary perspective
when considering exactly how to
validate or verify a method when setting
one up in your clinical lab
so the first thing is to consider do you
need to verify or do you need to
validate
um with that in mind cap provide a
definition for both
so analytical verification as per as per
cap is the process for which a
laboratory determines that an unmodified
fda cleared or approved test performs
according to the specifications set
forth
by the manufacturer when used as
directed
analytical validation however is the
process used to confirm
with objective evidence that a
laboratory developed test or modified
fda
cleared or approved tests delivers
uh reliable results for the intended
application so that's what the key
distinction there is verification is for
ibd tests that are used exactly as per
the manufacturer's recommendations
or if you're not using an ivd test then
you need to consider our
analytical validation
when uh validating laboratory developed
tests i suppose
there are a number of different factors
to consider
firstly those developed tests can have
develop
tests can be either developed in-house
it can be based off analyze specific
reagents that can be based off
research use only reasons or
investigational use reagents
and the example validation should be
sufficient to ensure that you have
confidence in the results that are
released by the
laboratory develop test one
very important factor to consider with
laboratory developed tests is the risk
that the result carries with
this is the factor that the the fda have
been looking at
over recent years and some of the the
high risk areas that are worthy of
consideration include for example
will the tests provide a direct
standalone result that guides a specific
therapeutic intervention
or is this a screening device for
serious diseases
and or conditions intended for use in
asymptomatic patients with no
other available confirmatory diagnostic
product or procedure
in those scenarios it is essential
that the result which is provided back
to clinical site is of high accuracy and
one that the
laboratory has confidence in a failure
to do that may result in
in detrimental events for the subject in
question
so when considering
validation and verification and labs
such as
icon central virtues or 100 dedicated
global clinical trials
would typically focus on ensuring that
the method is capable of
creating high quality analytical data
that is analytically precise
analytically accurate and and complete
i.e there are no gaps in the databases
sorry
the presence of gaps or less known
values are greater than values is
minimized
the reason why at least icon central
labs focus on this is that
by creating such high quality databases
we are able to pass back to our
customers
uh high quality database that enables
them to efficiently and accurately
assess the safety and efficacy of the
compound they're interested in
and in order to do that we spend
quite some time uh considering how to
validate
or verify the performance of an
individual assay
on screen at the moment you can see the
the typical format that we will use
when it comes to verifying or validating
an essay
so firstly we will typically perform at
least six assays
and we will evolve at these two
operators and then
precision experiments for example will
be performed typically in accordance
with ep 15
using uh typically five reps
per level uh over at least four levels
across at least five assays
the typical concentrations that we will
focus on will include
uh concentrations that sit at the upper
level normal
and lower level of normal and three
times the
element q and 0.7 times ulq
and routinely we the acceptance criteria
that we assign are based off
a total allowable error based system or
tda
and we usually expect the precision of
our methods to fall within one third of
the gea
then moving on we will perform accuracy
and in the rd and report marine study
which uses the same study performed with
five separate concentration levels five
reps per level in a single assay
we will expect to see appropriate levels
of linearity
and accuracy within that experiment
acceptance criteria here are you usually
50 eea and then we will also perform
accuracy assessments
with uh for example cap proficiency
samples wherever available or with
international standards wherever
available
or in the case of laboratory developed
tests
we will try to perform comparison
studies with another lab performing the
same method
using 20 or more samples
the acceptance criteria here will
typically be focused on those applied
but cap for the proficiency scheme
or based on 50 tda for example when
comparing with another lab
carryover experiments are are important
to perform when using automated devices
where
there's something that involves
a device that will go into every sample
year effectively what you're looking for
is to ensure
that there is no carryover of a high
sample
into a subsequent uh lower negative
sample that
inaccurately causes that lower negative
sample to now report down as positive
and carryover studies are performed in
accordance with again with
ep guidelines and with ep 10.
moving on then the other studies that
will often be performed
depending upon the features and the
needs of the assay include for example
evolution and linearity assessments
where samples will be diluted to confirm
that the
the actual donation step itself does not
impact the accuracy of the result
we do as a global laboratory perform um
biased assessments between our
respective roboties
so before a new lab our second lab
brings up a method
and we will expect them to be harmonized
with the primary location uh before they
start reporting our results
this is i guess not so much important
for individual laboratories but it is
important for
icon central laboratories who's
one of his goals is to provide
harmonized results across all locations
and we use cnsi ep9 to guide these
studies which effectively requires that
you run some
lead state samples over each of five
days as a means of accurately access
actually assessing the bias of the uh
that exists between the two respective
assets
as mentioned previously reference range
verification is performed in accordance
with cnsi ep28
in this document you can either verify
a reference range that exists for
example in the product insert
and to do that you can run 20 normal
samples and if 90
of them come back with the expected
result
you can verify however there is also an
option to establish a reference range in
which case
you csi recommend using 120 samples or
more
to establish the
range of results that would be expected
to be seen in the normal healthy
population
stability studies are all often required
and
with an icon we we use a token
change limit approach for performing
these studies where
one considers both the analytical
variation of the assay and the
biological variability of the alloys
as a means of identifying acceptable
levels of drift
uh up for another life um before
uh you know or excuse me so he
identified that that was a drifter
acceptable before
a result should be cancelled out and
then of course selectivity and
specificity studies
uh can be performed uh where necessary
uh and where for example the drug
of a drug being used in a study may be
suspected of interfering with the result
or
where a comparable for example
biological agent
where there is a risk that that may
cause a false positive result as well
and they are performed in accordance
with each of them icon in accordance
with the fda by 2018 criteria
once one finishes the validation process
it is of course essential that the focus
on maintaining the quality of the
athlete does not stop there
um with this in mind there are many
different procedures
available to ensure continued control of
the quality of individual assays once
they go live
and with an icon we use a
quite an evolved system which includes
for example daily qt monitoring weekly
gc monitoring multi-qc monitoring
based off the performance of the assays
when controlled with another
specific calculator and with west
cardinals
parts of this process that are worthy of
of consideration include for example
um being sure that you can control the
precision the bias
against the target and there are of
course numeric values that can be used
to track performance
of precision and bias against periods
using uh for example the
dsdi value for an assessment of bias and
cv or value for assessment of
precision compare it against peers
as one would expect the
the ability to maintain quality of that
sizes is highly
reliant on the inputs into the system
because
adding high quality inputs will maximize
the ability to drive high quality
outputs on that system
so with this in mind for example with an
icon
we would start off by trying to select
uh the most uh the highest performing
essay
for a specific analyte uh so for example
it would uh i'm sure we all most of the
call have experiences of situations
where
automated assets will create uh
typically higher quality i say than for
example in manual
um bench top assets um
you know so for example the cvs of
vitamin assets will almost always be
you know one to two fold tighter
than the cv of for example uh assays
acquire
manual competing interplays
it's also essential that gc rules are
assigned from the
very start the training is complete
before any individual picks
uh starts to run that essay and that
devices
are consistently and accurately
maintained
in addition it's important to have uh
incoming acceptance criteria for
for new lots of critical reasons and by
by creating uh this
these uh or by driving high quality
inputs
and by monitoring them before you
introduce them into the analytical
system
you maximize your chances of creating
high quality
analytical data outputs
the with the nikon we are very fortunate
to have a global qc group who will
monitor the performance of assets over
time
and that enables us to to ensure the
continued high quality performance of
our laboratories
in addition we also participate in for
example cap proficiency schemes which
provide
observational monitoring opportunities
where
one can assess at a given point in time
the accuracy and precision of that
laboratory
against other laboratories are also
participating in that scheme
some of the uh as the purpose of this
slide is to illustrate some of the
features
of our current uh
assay maintenance quality procedures
on the top line you can see the the
assay quality component pgc
and this is probably the most important
one that we use on a day-to-day basis
using qc enables you want to assess
um accuracy whether they're not say
precision one in an assay but also
it enables one to compare between and
different devices within a single lab
that are running the same assay
and also between different labs that are
running the same muscle within our
our laboratory network and this is very
helpful in the context of trying to
identify
any analytical systems that are at risk
on congenial specification
typical um calculations that can be used
to identify the
analytical systems that are going in
that manner that are at risk of going in
a specification include
for example the westgard rules which
enable detection of drift
and also there are cbr and sei
calculations which can be used
to assess a precision against peers and
buyers against
peers respectively as mentioned earlier
cap proficiency surveys also provide a
lot of benefit
and that they let you compare between
the laboratories in your network but
also
to let you compare yourself against
laboratories outside of your network
and the assessments against both
precision and bias can be made with
these cells albeit they are
predominantly used for bias
the the assessments that are listed you
can see in the
third row of the table in addition then
lots a lot is a key component
as a means of ensuring that the reagents
that are brought in are consistent
uh are performed in a manner that is
consistent with those used previously
and with an icon we assess a lot a lot
using a one-third tdi criteria so we
would not expect a new lot to introduce
the shift of more than a third of
the underlying specific tea and the more
among all of those assessments uh
it's it's important to note that the
use of the tea based system does enable
you to put
a single measure of analytical
performance
on each and every asset and the process
signal value
enables you to do this with an icon
we aim that our all of our assays
uh hit a sigma value of five or more uh
you know
you know we we wouldn't like the mods we
mean the six sigma standard but it's not
possible for all assets
and the minimum standard that we target
is uh there should be no one say
performing below
across the sigma value of three
so moving on so we've talked about uh
ibd assays we've talked about ldt assays
and there are another subset to the
companion diagnostic assets
so what are companion diagnostic club
companion diagnostic
devices can be in vitro diagnostic
devices or
an imaging tool that provides
information that is essential for the
safe and effective use of a
corresponding therapeutic product
the use of an ibd companion diagnostic
device
with a specific therapeutic product is
stipulated in the instructions
for use in the labeling of both the
diagnostic device and the client's
quality therapeutic product
as well as the labeling of any generic
equivalence and biosimilar equivalence
of the therapeutic product
the guidances issued by the fda are
there's quite a number of them uh some
of the key ones uh
that people are interested in anymore
and you can access are listed on screen
at the moment
one of the key factors associated with
with uh companion diagnostic
co-development therapeutic product
is to consider the level of
validation that should be performed on
your on your
ivd cdx device and the stage
stages at which that validation should
be performed
in the early stages or in pre-clinical
stages uh having a highly developed
product is not necessary
but it is essential that when you reach
the end
of your uh when your product reaches the
end of its pipeline when it's
when you aim to get marketing approval
for it
at that stage it is essential that you
have a
highly developed combined diagnostic
product which will meet from
the fda's requirements and as such
it is important to consider um
how you develop your product and the
stages at which you do that
because it's again it's critical to
ensure when you reach the end of the
you know when you reach the stage where
you're going to apply for marketing
improvement that you have
ready to go combining diagnostic assay
that has been
developed to the standard required by
the fda
so with that i will pass you back over
to roger
thank you andy so now let's move on to
some case studies
and we've selected these case studies
because they are not immediately
obvious as to whether they should be
performed with a bioanalytical method
validation
or executed in a clear lab setting so in
our first case study we're looking at
cytokine analyses
now typically cytokines are looked at in
an early phase
where we're trying to determine if there
is a safety signal
for an up or down regulation of a
particular cytokine or a group of
cytokines
and so therefore you would consider a
bioanalytical
lab to be more appropriate in doing the
initial assessments
and potential reporting for internal
decision making
but once particular cytokines have been
identified
as being disease or safety indicating
then those may well progress into a
clear lab setting
now the instrument platforms that you
might use
may be entirely identical so for example
in icon
we would do cytokines on a luminex
system which is a bead-based approach or
on an msd electrochemiluminescence
system
using the v-plex and so very common
example is the cytokine panel shown on
the right
being a pro-inflammatory panel for
exploratory
phase of clinical development so here in
our second
case study we're dealing with a genetic
disorder
in this case it's a syndrome called
criglia nasia
where the unfortunate individual has a
enzyme deficiency
being the bilirubin ugt enzyme
and so the body clears bilirubin by it
through glucoronidation
the ugt enzyme and if you're unable to
clear bilirubin
it will build up in the body leading to
jaundice
but in newborns you can lead to brain
damage
and ultimately death
so in this example we have two analytes
on the left hand side we have bilirubin
itself and then on the right hand side
we have the glucoronidated version
of bilirubin being the glucoronode
and from a clinical standpoint it would
be ideal
if we were able to measure both
bilirubin
and its glucaronide diagnostically
if you have high levels of bilirubin and
no levels of bilirubin glucuronode
in circulation you might suspect an
enzyme deficiency
such as the curriculum nature syndrome
now upon therapeutic intervention
in this case you might look at gene
therapy where you are now
adding or replacing a deficient
enzyme with the ugt1a1
protein you can monitor the levels of
bilirubin
and look to see if the glucoronide form
starts to appear in circulation
now because we're dealing with pivotal
pharmacodynamic endpoints
it seems pretty clear that we would
follow the fda
bioanalytical guidance for method
validation
now there is a nuance because if the
patients
being selected for gene therapy are
being screened
based on their bilirubin levels and lack
thereof of the bilirubin glucuronode
then there might be a thought that those
methods be performed in a clear
laboratory
now because it is gene therapy you
normally think of that as a one and done
and so the potential for therapeutic
dose decisions based on the bilirubin
glucuronide
levels may not be as important
now move on to case study four and we
stick with gene therapies yet again
but here we're looking at the vector
delivering the gene thera
so the introduction of a transgene
being the messenger rna into a cell
is often affected by the use of an
adenoviral vector
or in some cases elena viral vector
now there are at least a dozen different
subcategories
of adeno-associated viruses
and a drug company will select
a vector that is most suited for the
particular target
tissue that they're interested in now
because the vector is a virus
much like any virus in the wild there
may be individuals in the population
that have been pre-exposed to that virus
and thereby have antibodies to the viral
vector
and so therefore if you if that
individual is being dosed
with a transgene encapsulated in that
viral vector
it is likely that the body's immune
system will react
and clear the vector before it's been
able to
transmit the transgene to the target
cell
in other words from a inclusion or an
exclusion criteria in a clinical trial
you would want to pre-screen patients
for those that do
or do not have the viral antibodies
that being said when you're assessing
immunogenicity
that is quite commonly done in a
bioanalytical laboratory
and so in this example the
immunogenicity assay
may well be established in a
bioanalytical lab
but when it is being used for screening
criteria
in a clinical setting
then it needs to migrate to a clear lab
and so our approach at icon
is to develop the initial screening
assay
in the bioanalytical laboratory
following the fda's immunogenicity
guidance
and of course industry best practice and
what is quite common for a screening
assay
is that you're looking for about a five
percent false positive rate
having a false positive rate would it
would mean
that a small percentage of the
population
would be excluded from treatment
but from a conservative aspect you would
not be treating anybody
that had the potential for pre-existing
antibodies to the viral vector
and so once the screening essay has been
developed
and then validated in the bioanalytical
laboratory
we would we are now ready to transfer it
into our clear lab
now we would consider the bioanalytical
method validation sufficient
for establishing a lab developed test in
our clear
laboratory we would then
undergo the requirements of a clear
validation
and then because icons central lab
exists in the state of new york
we would submit to new york state health
for final approval
and so once efficacy has been
demonstrated
for the therapeutic intervention
the next logical step would be to
collaborate with a reagent vendor
to develop an in vitro diagnostic to
then
in clinical medicine be able to
pre-screen
those patients that are predisposed to
having
antibodies to the viral vector and
thereby
not subjecting them to a therapeutic
intervention
that would have little chance of success
and so that concludes our case studies
and so hopefully with these examples
you're able to determine for yourselves
when a clear lab setting or a
bioanalytical
lab setting might be more appropriate
and so with these case studies i hope
we've shown that it is not a clear-cut
decision as to whether a bioanalytical
lab or a clear lab
should be performing the biomarker
method development
and validation
and with that we'd like to conclude and
on behalf of my co-presenter
we hope that you found this presentation
informative
and if there are any follow-up questions
or feedback please feel free to reach
out to us
and our emails are presented on screen
thank you for your attention